bonjour et bienvenue sur des gonades
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
aujourd'hui actualité assez chargé avec
le match peut repasser qui vient de se
terminer
également au programme hicham hamdouchi
vainqueur du continent africain pour
présenter cette émission nous avons bien
entendu cet effet de lasbordes bonjour
stéphane bon je vois loin et comme
invité exceptionnel puisqu'il revient du
continent sud américain il revient de
guyane donc il est extrêmement gros est
extrêmement chaud il s'agit de jean-luc
chavanon bonjour jean luc ou bonjour
eloi ex alors tout de suite comment ça
s'est passé avec les serpents et les
mygales la guyane donc c'est un pays
extrêmement sauvage et je dois avouer
que ça a été assez flippant est donc
tout à fait une partie d'échecs au
milieu de la jungle
et oui donc comme je l'expliquais tout à
l'heure pour le live g
j'ai joué j'ai joué aux échecs donc en
pleine forêt amazonienne
j'explique un petit peu les raisons je
vais pas remonte trop envie de jouer aux
échecs mais j'étais avec des amis qui
voulaient jouer une partie comme ça avec
un grand m donc je leur ai dit pourquoi
pas surtout que quand autour d'un feu
quand on a peur des pétioles et tout ça
est bien y'a rien de tel qu'une partie
des chacals aveugle pour oublier un
petit peu tout ce qui est autour l
aveugle en plus jean-luc avant de partir
en guyane donc pour des vacances il faut
bien le souligner eh bien tu vas jouer
le championnat de france d'échecs à
marseille et c'était une catastrophe
puisque tout le monde attendait comme
outsider possible et finalement tu
termines dernier détaché
donc comment comment as tu vécu ce
tournoi et quelles sont les conclusions
que de partir et j'ai l'impression que
je l' ai vécu un petit peu comme comme
le parcours du combattant dans la forêt
amazonienne donc j'étais entouré de
d'embûches et de et de prédateurs et
et je crois que j'ai été la proie donc
de tous les joueurs ça s'est plutôt mal
passée j'étais pas très bien préparé et
je pourrai donc expliquer plus en détail
specchio téléspectateurs plus en détails
donc un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
dans ce tournoi bon qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qui peut expliquer que tu commences par
un demi point sur sept alors que c'est
un sport vraiment inhabituel c'est ça
n'arrive jamais oui parce qu'il peut
expliquer c'est simple c'est que j'ai
très mal commencé j'ai commencé avec 0 /
3g j'avais gâché une partie contre
christian bauer et je n'avais pas eu
trop de réussite et j'essayais de me
refaire après mais c'était très
difficile et comme les poules sont
qualificatives et qu' il faut quatre
qualifiés seulement par cool
après donc dans dans ce début de
dans cette première phase c'est
extrêmement difficile de marquer ne
serait ce qu un demi point puisque les
joueurs tentent leur maximum à chaque
partie il se trouve quand même que dans
la poule basse je me suis quand même
nettement mieux comportés puisque j'ai
fait la moyenne et
et j'ai finalement quand même gagné une
partie comme quoi je fais quand même un
petit peu récompensée puisque j'ai joué
mes parties à fond j'ai essayé de faire
des choses intéressantes et de
d'intéresser le public
j'ai quand même gagné la dernière partie
et ça m'a fait extrêmement plaisir du
corps est-ce que c'est pas ce que c'est
le contrecoup de tentes nouveau titre de
grand maître puisque tu es grand maître
depuis depuis pas longtemps
depuis le depuis trois ou quatre mois tu
veux tu as eu ta ta dernière norme est
ce que c est ce que suite à cette aune
ans tu sais que tu vas être grand maître
est ce que tu n'as pas un peu relâché
psychologiquement il faut croire que oui
puisque tous les joueurs qui qui ont
tenu le titre ont tous expliqué que
après le titre ça devient pendant
quelques mois c'est assez difficile
puisqu'il ya un relâchement total c'est
se fixer de nouveaux objectifs c'est
difficile puisque après le titre de
grand maître
il n'y a plus beaucoup de titres qui
existent donc c'est vrai que bon un
champion du monde champion du monde
champion du monde ça pourrait être une
idée devant cholet y penser bien alors
tout de suite donc après son retour son
champ quatre ans nous allons passer à
l'actualité donc le match europe asie
l'europe s'impose assez facilement mais
tout d'abord détail des équipes avec
commentaires donc de stéphane et jean
luc l'équipe européenne était plutôt
forte avec garry kasparov faut qu'on ait
un chic et évidemment c'est pas mal
qu'est ce qui explique stéphane d'après
toi le fait que garry kasparov joue ce
match de phase i qui est donc en partie
semi rapide puisque on sait que pour
habiter garry kasparov il faut quand
même des arguments massue
oui donc je pense tout simplement les
organisateurs avaient de quoi le pays
bon je vois pas d'autre explication
à d'autres solutions parmi les quatorze
mois disons que ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant à noter la composition des
équipes
c'est qu'en fait avec etienne bacrot et
loïc 20 de valeo fait ils m'ont invité
je prends les vainqueurs de leurs
championnats respectifs puisque vingt
deux pays doit être champion des pays
bas
oui tout à fait et etienne bacrot et
champion de france donc ils n'ont pas
choisi les meilleurs joueurs européens
parce que c'est évident qu'on aurait eu
de surtout des russes
c'est clair éventuellement peter l'écho
ils ont également invité grigorovitch
qui est champion de belgique
voilà donc ils ont évité les champions
nationaux des donc c'est intéressant
champion de belgique avec cent pour cent
pour cent mais on se rappelle
performance exceptionnelle de mira
gourévitch qui gagne le tournoi avec 9
sur 9
c'est bouleversant un résultat pareil
également dans l'équipe de zohra
bataille karachi lui qui a été
entraîneur de kasparov entraîneur
etienne bacrot donc dé s'en tire plutôt
bien et émile site off ce qui a était
anciennement champion du monde junior et
récemment champion d'europe symptômes
individuels à chaque tournant tout est
champion d'israël aussi non je ne crois
pas je ne compte même
donc voilà l'équipe une très forte
équipe d'europe effectivement en face on
a mis une équipe asiatique donc on
rappelle que la russie stéphane a quand
même une partie européenne et une partie
asiatique
ouais ce qui fait donc on retrouve des
joueurs comme cuisine janov par exemple
ou vladimirov qui sont russes ou
république soviétique
donc c'était une janov extrêmement forte
de rostam qasemi janot fonder une
occasion le voir à cannes un jeune
joueur très talentueux ayant échoué le
joueur chinois fly dimitrov a bientôt
doubt yanhai et recherche
le joueur australien donc voilà les
équipes sont effectivement pas forcément
équilibré l'europe s'est imposée 52 à 46
assez facilement et la partie que nous
allons vous commentez et tirer de cette
compétition c'est la partie garry
kasparov contre rogers donc le numéro un
de l'équipe de rock d'europe contre le
numéro dernier le 6 ou de l'équipe
asiatique donc a priori une boucherie un
patrick type mais c'est là que la partie
est intéressante c'est on voit la façon
dont gary kasparov bas un joueur
informant m bien évidemment le gers et
un fort goût en maître et de bas
extrêmement facilement
c'est quand même surprenant un grand
maître pareil ti ne sait pas quoi faire
alors qu'il a les blancs contre garry
kasparov
oui donc un joueur qui essayez donc de
jouer dans une position extrêmement
solide mais qui et qui finalement donc
de lui-même créé un déséquilibre dans
cette partie c'est vrai que l'on
s'interroge on évalue mal à comprendre
puisque ce jour et est quand même réputé
et très connu pour être un joueur
extrêmement extrêmement fort c'est juste
donc tout de suite nous allons passer en
incrustation
et à droite de l'échiquier laisser place
à la position et maintenant c'est parti
pour le commentaire de cette partie ian
rogers contre garry kasparov
championnats d'europe à zico rodgers
allait bien rogers est les blancs et des
jupes des quatre cajas caisses déjà mon
choix je pense parce que prévu que tous
les joueurs qui tentent eux quatre camps
kasparov font complètement laminé et y
compris à nantes le palais enfin les
meilleurs joueurs du monde donc c'est
peut-être cette chronique d'ailleurs un
jeu que d4 contre kasparov donc
semble-t-il ses larmes quand même la
plus la plus solide
d'ailleurs je crois qu'on ne rappelle
pas que c'est souvent mais jean-luc
chavanon à lui-même choix contre garry
kasparov
mais oui j'ai joué contre garry kasparov
en 93 oui je pars équipe je jouais à
l'époque pour le club de cannes
d'ailleurs je joue toujours pour le club
de cannes et kasparov a joué une petite
saison donc en france il jouait pour le
club d'auxerre le croit et
et donc bon on avait décidé de me mettre
face à face à gagner face aux grands
gary est bon ça c'est
très mal passée est à jouer de la belle
et blanc non j'ai joué c4 j'ai joué une
anglaise je me suis préparé j'avais créé
surprise contre gary j'étais arrivé avec
un petit peu de retard et il ça n'a pas
suffi à déstabiliser sa pas suffi à le
déstabiliser d'ailleurs j'étais lui
arriver avec dix minutes de retard
garry kasparov m'a fixé pendant 10
minutes sans toucher une pièce d'accord
on dirait que kasparov et quand même un
joueur psychologique cyclo logique mais
comme appareil qui avait fait des il
avait fait des commentaires sur ton
style de jeu je crois après la partie on
se rappelle des deux déclarations phare
stéphane genêt prévu aucun coup de
jean-luc chavanon ou et déjà première
déclaration construit donc pas forcément
une remarque positive jean luc et la
deuxième remarque c'est jacques schab
annoncé le jour le plus faible que j'ai
joué depuis dix ans ouais ça c'était
donc les deux remarques de garry
kasparov
après la partie contre jean-luc mais
effectivement ça avait dû me surprendre
comme la façon dont tu vas arrive à
trouver des coûts vraiment alternatif
ouais c'était une partie très curieuse
bon quand il dit quand il disait ça je
suppose que bon c'est que le
déséquilibre avaient été installés assez
tôt je n'avais pas trop réussi mon
ouverture et
et au lieu d'essayer de choisir des
solutions simples j'ai voulu jeu fut
compliqué les contrôles gary kasparov
c'était pas une bonne solution pas
forcément la meilleure solution donc
retour sur la partie faut dire quand
même caspar en fait rarement oublie de
faire des attaques verbales sur ses
adversaires bien entendu c'est quels
qu'ils soient
c'est systématique c'est systématique
qui les guignols qui avait perdu
d'ailleurs de toute façon il essayait de
ces attaques
d'ailleurs je crois c'est à dire ça ça
m'avait beaucoup affecté l'époque
j'avais fait une conférence de presse et
j'avais contre attaqué en disant que
bonds a vu aucun des coupes kasparov
exactement tout à fait longue partie de
la semaine
rodgers contre garry kasparov des 4 as
joué par ian rogers camani f6 et là tout
de suite rassuré yves fouchet cinq coups
rarement joué il faut dire qu on joue
beaucoup plus régulièrement ses 4 mais
ça les deux secousses nouveau
intéressant c'est un coup intéressant ça
menace francophonie avec doublement des
pions qui casse la structure de journée
alors il ya beaucoup de réactions
possibles jean-luc je crois que tu
connais assez bien cette ligne ont peu
joué ces 5 on peut jouer des 5 où on
peut jouer kim audio 4 ou aussi s'en
fait tous les coups sont possibles et
tous les coups sont possibles et garry
kasparov je crois avait déjà joué avec 6
oui il joue régulièrement et qui m'a dit
aux 4,6 avec le sport aux six cavaliers
f3 par exemple il avait joué donc ça
contre contre un joueur anglais qui
s'appelle anthony miles et ils avaient
fait match nul avec les avec les noirs
donc je pense que rodgers a joué ce coup
j'ai cinq queues qui a annoncé une
ouverture qui porte un nom qui s'appelle
l' attaque trop pauvres ce qui donc de
gros dger sajoo et l'attaquent trompeuse
ce qui probablement parce que elle et
elle sort des sentiers et trompe elle
trompe elle trop pauvres ce qui est elle
sort des sentiers battus tout en restant
d'ouverture extrêmement solide voilà
donc c'était le choix de rogers des cinq
le choix de garry kasparov donc 17 des
cinq un coût tout à fait normal
positionnelle contrôle du centre qui
permet fou prend ainsi c'est la seule
justification puisque les noirs menace
dans cette version de jean luc cayez 17
tout simplement suivi de chasse âge de
fou donc faut prendre six points et 6
donc là on reprend des pions veut et
maintenant il ya la peur de fou pour les
noirs et les blancs en revanche on
affaiblit cette structure de purement
donc les blancs en étions mieux placé
que les noirs l'annoncé a priori une
partie qui va pas être extrêmement
complexe tactiquement il y aura pas trop
de calculs de bamyan mais intéressante
sur le plan positionnelle le 3 donc
normal on met les pieds rosso cases
noires pia plus le fou oui et en sort un
sort le fou de cases blanches fou des
six alors ce qu'il faut rappeler dans ce
genre de structure il ya quelque chose
de très important c'est que le jeu des
noirs va se passer donc de ce côté là du
côté la chaîne d'options comme toujours
les blancs eux leurs chaînes d'options
va par là donc les noirs ont joué la
gauche de l'échiquier et les blancs à
droite
enfin l inverse chacun va jouer sur sa
gauche mais atteint tout simplement il
faut voir que les pions isoler les tours
doubler ici favorise un contrôle des
noirs sur la colonne e et principalement
sur cette case de 4 donc on va tenter de
ramener ce cavalier sur la case aux 4
c'est très logique
les blancs est en revanche clairement
contre le fou des six qui est une très
mauvaise pièce et on peut imaginer une
finale cavaliers contre sous des six où
le cavalier s'en sortira très bien
puisque le fou ne peut pas défendre ses
propres pions enfin bon c'est assez
compliqué mais en gros tout ça pour
résumer que le fou des 6 et noir est pas
une si bonne chose que ça est-ce qu'il
peut pas défendre l'option donc ici c4
alors ça c'est un coup extrêmement
responsable puisque normalement dans
cette position on préfère jouer b3
d'abord et c4 après pour justement sur
la prise en c4 pouvoir reprendre d'un
pion c'est un autre plan qui existe
c'est qu'un tout de suite ça existe
aussi mais c'est
bien reconnu puisque ici on prend ces
quatre avec ouverture de ligne on fout
pensée quatre normales petit rock cha
cha rock qu'elle manie ses trois
logiques comme ça dans ses pièces pour
l'instant les blancs et pas de faiblesse
on peut dire que cette position est
quand même assez agréable à jouer côté
blanc mais sur le long terme la paire
neuf on peut toujours se réveiller la
garenne tasses par jour un premier coup
intéressant un coût qu'il faut trouver
on n'a pas forcément envie de jouer oui
donc qu'avec export qui décide donc de
mieux comprendre le centre est qui
rejoue donc une pièce qui a déjà joué
mais c'est un pion oui mais c'est un
coup très important don qui contrôle il
dit sur contrôler la case e cat avec son
pion et éventuellement il garde la
possibilité de jouer f 104 4 pour ouvrir
les lignes ce qui serait un avantage vu
la paire de food des noirs oui tout à
fait en fait hier qu'il arrive à bien
contrôler la case aux 4 et que sur f4 le
couple a eu quatre est impossible et
bien ce sens là ça va ouvrir les yeux et
ça va très bien pour lui
il prépare évidemment également le
planquer et 17 et cavaliers 6 et qu'il y
avait rien qui vaille abscisse pour
arriver sur la case au câble donc voilà
comment ça se passe sachant que pour
l'instant le développement est pas
vraiment une priorité tension de
position puisque tout simplement il n'y
a pas d' attaques rapides qui se profile
un cavalier f3 donc c'est des gaz par an
il joue son plan qui avalise 17 les
blancs rock c'est logique
cavani m6 maintenant hélas les blancs
doivent se demander qu'est ce que je
fais ici mais parce que plein et nord il
est simple on va sûrement jouer toro 8
magnifique cavalier ou quatre tours 8
s'annonce déjà f4 way oussad menace déjà
f4 ensuite on va installer quatre sur
lequel il prend cavaliers on prendra du
pion on pourrait éventuellement aussi
développé revenir le développer pouces
et 8 en juin des 6es fougassettes par
exemple sur cette bande donald qui peut
être également une bonne chose donc le
plan des noirs on voit les bleus eux et
doivent choisir quelque chose donc là
c'est pas évident on est face à gary
kasparov on rappelle que ce n'est pas
assez rapide faut trouver quelque chose
puisque dans quelques coups et bien
c'est les noirs qui vont prendre
l'initiative donc rogers tente une idée
intéressante il jockey et les cinq
attaques le fou avec la ferme intention
de le prendre
wen mais tout à fait mérité ce parc ne
veut pas donner le fou et qu'il faut et
7 est maintenant cavalier aux 5,4
centrale voilà il a mis ses
comme une des 5 permet curieuse scène
finale exactement puisque avant on ne
pouvait pas le faire puisqu'il y avait
franck avec voulait simplement est tout
à fait mature prend calé j'ai cadre d un
pion ici c'est 6
on chasse ce qu'elle aimait 5 qui
revient en c3 donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
les blancs ont joué beaucoup qu'elle ait
des cinq puis retour mais de l'autre
côté c'est si les empêche le parti le c6
empêche le fou s'est vite de se
développer sur bessette ça bloque un peu
loose évident qui maintenant a plus
beaucoup de cas de sa disposition parce
que six c'est comme une case oui mais un
jour pas comme il ya les fous prince une
dame b3 et des faiblesses sur carte
blanche est bondée cette île est sous
l'emprise du cavalier 2,5 donc se
foutent un peu immobilisé donc très
clairement dans cette position le
problème des noirs thank you sein du
vent de l'attaqué très vite baisser la
pression sur fc est aussi les blancs
peut-être menace de jouer d'un b 3 oui
avec une grosse pression sur sept et
peut-être même pourrait menacer de temps
en temps des prises direct sur leflux en
fait donc impératif l'attaquent de ce
cavalier ou 5 dont il ya deux options il
ya food et 6 où le coût de garry
kasparov qui a 17 qui est très logique
et 17
on revient on a l'impression que c'est
quand même 8 ce salaire est logique
salaire est logique puisque on rejoue
deux fois la même pièce à noter que dans
cette caution recherche aurait pu jouer
peut-être milliers de francs bonjour sur
le plus jeune cavalière proches je
réfléchisse à ce coup mais là j'imagine
que kasparov aurait sans doute b
symbolique à tcc ont vraiment joué aux
tirs 5
oui le fou bessette est pur il essaie
d'obtenir un petit peu le une position
dans l'esprit de l'aveyron de la maison
de la semi slave qu'on est tout à fait
c'est juste donc rodgers a pas envie de
revenir
très logiquement en f3 ça paraît curieux
de revenir et joue donc f4 blanc dont la
position centrale blain dans la position
du québec de 5
maintenant on voit bien qu'on ne pourra
jamais le chasser en juin m6 compte ça
affaiblit la case de 495 au cap mais il
faut voir c'est que ce qui va venir vos
je lève à échanger de ses valises et des
sacs dans la nature donc ça va difficile
de oued
en fait là la colonne aussi en échange
la colonie de bât être faible et le pion
aux trois et deux femmes mais oui pour
l'instant mais ce qui est bien le sien
qui est trop fort pour l'instant il est
beaucoup trop fort il faut absolument le
chat c'est donc soit on le prend soit on
va mettre le fou pour le prendre mais
d'autres dans tous les cas
les blancs pour ouvrir la colonne f
c'est sur ce qu'on en fait on voudrait
chasser le cavalier stéphane en jouant
le coup et 7 et 6,5 en pole mais on peut
pas puisque c'est chloé ouais donc on a
des problèmes dans cette position c'est
vrai que la pression blanche a l'air
plutôt pas mal on va voir comment
kasparov réagi alors quand vous êtes
sous pression comme ça
un conseil puisqu'il faut bien donner
des conseils il faut échanger parce
qu'on ne sait pas quoi faire on échange
les piaggio spa jean-luc si tu as des
conseils comme ça que tu donnes à t&d
avait régulièrement mais voilà on m'a
appris ça très vite quand on ne sait
plus quoi faire
on échange quelques pièces et tout de
suite on trouve de nouvelles idées oui
et puis dans cette position faut voir
qu'on ne change pas n'importe quelle
pièce d échange d'un cavalier a eu cinq
donc d'un cavalier qui est au centre de
l'échiquier qui attaque qui attaquent le
pion f c'est donc qu'ils aient qui
paralyse les noirs c'est une bonne pièce
le cavaliere 17 une pièce comme une
autre tout à fait jeune cavalier prend
aux 5es 2.5 très logique là on ouvre la
colonne f avec des menaces régulièrement
par exemple on peut imaginer que les
blancs vont jouer dame b3 pour rien et
aux quatre pour casser ce qui enlève
ensuite avoir le une trilogie sur le
plus bref c'est tout à fait aller toutes
les pièces gary kasparov ou g6 dans
cette pression est ici ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de connaître
l'évaluation de cette position alors
jean-luc comment faire pour pour dire
qui est mieux et pourquoi donc dans
cette position pour pour évaluer
davantage il faut enfin pour évaluer la
position il faut il faut déjà regarder
un petit peu donc le nombre de pièces
donc là il ya égalité matérielle
ensuite on voit que les noirs ont la
paire de fou alors ils ont affaire de
fous il se trouve que dans cette
position de les fous sont un petit peu
bloqué pour l'instant notamment repoussé
vite
voilà le fossé 8 donc on peut chercher
des solutions pour débloquer la
situation on a trouvé tout à l'heure
donc le coût 17 des 5 et qui a un coût
extrêmement intéressant puisque après on
peut éventuellement jouer soit ces cinq
hommes dans une errance soif ou 17 ou de
préparer donc l'ouverture et donc ça ça
fait partie des possibilités et
éventuellement ouvrir le centre est
attaquée le 3 voilà donc en fait ce
qu'il faut à mon avis ce qu'il faut ce
qui est très important de dire c'est que
si les noirs ne font rien avec les pions
eh bien ils vont être tout simplement
écrasé là il faut absolument qu'ils
libèrent leurs plans de ce côté là sinon
ils n'ont pas de plan ils peuvent pas
sortir leurs pièces une fois qu'ils
repoussaient ses deux pions et mille
fois en 17
effectivement on va voir la position qui
va complètement changer avec en fait
l'objectif des noirs tout simplement
comme souvent avec la paire de fou c'est
d'ouvrir les lignes et les diagonales
d'un entendu donc ouvrir l'appétit
ici rogers ou cavaliers au 2me revenir
probablement f4 peut-être en g3 ou
peut-être apparaît que le coût de 3 e 4
b52 kasparov ça c'est pas une surprise
four b3 c'est simple maintenant c'est 5
donc la c5
jean-luc à un coût très important qu'on
responsable parce que ça permet quand
même des cinq qui craignent qu'ils ont
passée voilà alors tout de suite dont
une première variante évidemment des
cinq ne marche pas c'est fun il faut le
préciser ça va perdre un pion très vite
donc on commence par jouer dans cette
position c4 le fou revient sur ses
débouchés il faut le food aux alliances
et 2 et maintenant je m'appelle et une
attaque double jeu s'est plu à base de
quoi oui c'est ça ou je fous ces cinq
dans un premier temps on va mettre à
table 2.3 et cloud est tout à fait donc
si on peut tenter de défendre ce tueur
de 3 on joue par exemple dam des deux
dames des deux minots qui défend pions
mais là tout simplement tour vite et on
ne peut plus défendre le plan de 5 voilà
donc ça doit faire c'était c'était à
vérifier exactement c'est une vente très
importantes sur ces 5
les blancs évidemment tout naturellement
envie de jouer des 5es des six mais ils
ne peuvent pas ils n'ont pas le temps
puisqu'il ya ces quatre fous c'est
simple on évacue de fouet en attaque le
pion que ça donc première variante
importante ces cinq ne permet pas des 5
et donc après on va prendre la
traversant l'inde - c'est la partie qui
me f 4 food et 7 passes et le fou une
belle diagonale même thème alors là
stéphane encore une fois sur des cinq
ont perdu matériel très vite on commence
par ces quatre comme toujours ma c4 le
pion des cinq vont être en prison
peugeot j5 est fou c'est ça qui a
toujours ses cinq jours dam des deux est
maintenant encore tous ruinés tour itway
c'est thématiques et puis là on voit que
le sport sont quand même au top
les fous se révèle être une arme
extrêmement percutante
ce qui est intéressant donc dans cette
manoeuvre c'est de voir donc la clarté
des idées de garry kasparov puisque il
abandonne finalement le centre il laisse
à son adversaire la possibilité
d'installer un duo qui semble-t-il est
très impressionnant e5 des 5 mai mais en
réalité ce duo n'est complètement
inefficace face au début d'initiatives
que lancent les noirs dans cette
position oui on va rappeler la force
d'un duo central comme le 5d 5 1 c'est
en général qu'on peut jouer soit aussi
ce soit 10,6 on peut pousser les pions
on contrôle énormément de gaz puisse
contrôler les quatre caisses de vent
donc c'est extrêmement fort c'est pour
ça qu'il faut toujours vérifier si vous
pouvez installer un duo dion vérifier
les drones tactiques affiliés qui
appuient en ont pas instantanément j'en
prends ces 5
rodgers a craqué ouais là il me le dira
les cracks
mais rogers abandonne finalement il se
dit c'est vrai et on tombe on dire t'as
manoeuvre avec des cinqs et 5 contre
mon plan de m'installer au centre donc
on va essayer un petit peu de garder du
jeu pour nous font b3 on élimine donc ce
plan c'est oui puisque le plan ces
menaces est systématiquement aller en c4
mes oncles élimine a prévu de lancer
cinq français 5 rogers doit défendre le
pion de 3 et cède définitivement
l'initiative circulant cette eau noire
de maintenant d'attaqué on voit deux
superbes fou le pion aux 3 il y des
emprises et melain portage de recherche
dans cette pétition ces exemptions au
centre va quoiqu'il arrive à l'est en
russie ce n'est avec détroit est très
fort avec 4 aussi des menaces
importantes ce rêve s'être notamment le
pion variant aussi donc en fait il a
bradé son centre puissant pour jouer e 5
e 6 et casser un peu le truc autour du
roi noir réveiller son font bêtement
pour l'un de ceux qu'il a plus de foot
recasement donc il faut pas attaquer ou
dameuse 2 voilà pour défendre ce pion et
stefano pioli en attaque
clavet si redoutable oui c'est vrai mais
bon qu'à sport à l'initiative et il joue
dmb 6006 porte une initiative et ils le
prouvent et le prouve donc maintenant il
faut donc soit défendre ce furent trois
soit trouvée du concret je n'en peux
plus des fonds d'actions étrangères lui
puisque la menace de dames b6 et de
jouer trop vite par exemple salda
toujours à 1,8 et bien sûr aussi son
prend et puisque ça sera défendue et par
la trop vite et par la donne des six
nouvelles blessé c'est un coût qui
attaque et qui défend cette casque les
os 6
donc il faut que je me dise maintenant
faut prendre trois échecs l'échec foule
entassée rocha et issifou prend 1,4
ouais on peut crier trop fort dont il
faut prendre le cavalier et on ne
pouvait pas reprendre un os 6
puisqu'après qui on prend aussi ce
cavalier prendre si c'est très fort
puisque ça tape la tour et fuites et sa
menace d'un échec à la découverte du fou
bêtement oui par exemple d'ailleurs
comme à chaque fois la découverte on
peut envisager qui a laissé cinq échecs
et d'un profond bon alors c'est en fait
c'est un échec qui interpose une pièce
entre les dames il vous permet de
prendre le pouls
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est très fort
en plus donc évidemment menaces étaient
inquiets et prendre tout cas
généralement je crois tout à base des
chèques du four b3 donc ici j'en crois
si ce n'est pas possible on est guéri a
tout prévu
le cavalier il faut l'éliminer parce
qu'on attaque et des monstres ou et en
plus on voit que ce fonds est roi jean
luc peut pas vraiment servir à une
attaque quelconque une nonne ont donc
donc on les lecavalier trop fort il faut
il faut s'en débarrasser
24 j'en prends acte cet échec n'a pas
l'air bien mais il faut bouger le roi
revanche excellent way tampon f k
maintenant le bilan dans cette position
m'intéresse énormément pourquoi est ce
que les noirs sera mieux donc pourquoi
les noirs seraient mieux dans cette
position lors senti mieux les noirs sont
mieux donc on va voir finalement donc
même si le pion le pion f7 est quand
même relativement bien placé il a une
case de la case de promotion mais
malheureusement donc ce plan est absente
et isolées c'est à dire sans le contrôle
du four b3 il serait il serait pris
immédiatement le les colonnes donc les
noirs ont toujours l'initiative c'est à
vous de jouer c'est à le lancer le donc
de jouer le coup qu'ils ont joué par
exemple qui était la première pierre de
jeter la première pierre
et le fou bessette est extrêmement fort
puisqu'il attaque donc ils contrôlent la
grande diagonale à 8 h avec une vue
directe sur le roi et le plan g2 donc
maintenant après tourrades évite les
noirs ont également fini leur
développement
oui ce qui est une raison aussi
essentiel est bon si on regarde la
structure de pions encore une fois la
structure noir est meilleur que la
structure blanche parce que probable ans
ce pur avec 7 va va il faut évaluer les
fans il faut il faut bien comprendre que
ce plan arrive cet ancien de l'attak il
est très fort mais là après un coup de
défense comme dan f6 ne peut pas donner
un seul échec avec les pièces blanches
restantes
il y aurait un cavalier pour venir en
utilise les noirs les blancs sera très
bien mais là près de 9,6 toutes les
lignes sont fermés et dès qu'on est en
finale on va le pire est que cet hymne
tombe donc un pion à vii c'est à double
tranchant genre but premier de la taxe
est bien quand il n'a pas fait la caisse
qui se passe sur une des restaurants
d'am-dam cinq échecs par exemple
d'annoncer que chez caleiras efforts
vains puisque ça tape le plan b 5 donc
sur des murs d'un v6 on pourrait prendre
le tube et 5
alors justement stéphane c'est là qu'il
y a un problème il ya là le site
facebook
dimpre en bessin voilà et la foux projet
de four en g2 est envisageable
d'ailleurs est très fort puisque après
roy reprend les deux il y as dame g5
entre autres prendre d'autres
possibilités d'un premier de kingdom
on a trouvé deux échecs gagne à tours 1
et on voit assez facilement en cas si
vous êtes en train de calculer ce genre
de variantes eh bien on voit très vite
que les blancs n'auront rien quand on
aura plus de tours pourquoi parce que la
dame continue à contrôler cette
diagonale qui l'aideront à clé de la
défense noire donc là vous pourrez aller
prendre la tour tranquille il y aura
aucune contre attaque possible ce qui ce
qui est intéressant dans cette partie
c'est que garry kasparov donc à contrer
donc la stratégie des attaques de son
adversaire
donc il lui laisse la possibilité de
s'imposer sur casse blanche est chez lui
donc à capuchon avec 7 mai il a prévu
tout simplement que grâce à une seule
pièce saddam il pourrait donc cocon
projet défendre contrôler les autres
cases les cases noires et les contrôler
de manière à n'avoir aucun problème donc
ici les noirs sens mieux
indiscutablement puisse désormais
initiative tourner un fou aux cadres
donc ça c'est un coup de vis
donc voilà la plaie oui donc garé qui
décide donc de avec avec ce placement
fou au centre de l'échiquier
il décide donc de 2
de profiter pour but de provoquer donc
eu un manque de coordination chez les
pièces lourdes
disons qu'ils bougent toutes les pièces
lourdes et blanc de la population les
deux tours et la dass ça parce qu'on ne
joue ne joue plus du tout et sont très
très mal développées dans cette position
de la torah f4 et tout intérêt se
retrouvaient pariant sur des 1
exactement donc ici rogers il craque
il craque puisqu'il va prendre la
qualité on se demande pourquoi ce choix
bahour déjà probablement a compris qu'à
long terme dans cette position si je
ramène par la tour f 4 sur f2 oui s'il
joue donc des coûts et c'est assez
anodin à long terme le fougueux 4 va
exercer une pression sur le plonger de
qui sera telle que les noirs vont
finalement quoi qu'il arrive
lol l'emporter cette position est donc
plutôt que de péniblement souffrir dans
une pression inférieure donc pourquoi
elle inférieure va on leur rappelle le
pion à vii est faible les blancs n'ont
pas d'attac et toutes les pièces lourdes
blanches sont muselés pour l'instant
parce x 4 mai nord initiative donc tout
ça c'est tout un tas d'inconvénients
rogers
il veut jouer son va-tout en fait
survécu teintées fou fou ces deux
peut-être pour jouer pour jouer une
finale avec un point de moins entre gary
taylor n'en reste que vous voit que le
fou est venu en c2 effectivement ça fait
jouer toutes les pièces lourdes
voilà c'est dit mais ouais mais c'est
donc tout le moins des fois on n'a rien
on fait un nul quoi à contrecoeur par un
pack en question et surtout que bon un
peu fous ces deux gars il aurait
peut-être ne pas tarder à garder le fou
62 considèrent peut-être que son pur et
7 oblige une tour à der sar à rester
dans son camp oui ce qu'il faut voir
c'est quand même que la position n'est
pas perdue après 3,4 on va te regarder
si on prend le cadre d'un prendre quatre
si on a un pion pour la qualité c'est
sur mais bon qu'est ce qui se passe on
menace éventuellement d'un médecin suite
d'un prend maintenant tu te fous c'était
en juillet il faut voir également que
cette tour est fluide
elle n'est pas vraiment dans l'action
elle est assez loin d'y être allé
visible et palpable c'est donc la
position est encore tout à fait jouable
c'est un choix c'est un choix
oppositionnel de rogers
je donne la qualité mais j'ai un de
l'initiative d'un des quatre donc la
garde espoir qu on lui dit pas deux fois
qu'il a dû
plus d'un matériel ça provoque chez lui
une envie incroyable d'échanger toutes
les pièces oui donc là ça change très
classique
kasparov qui décide des ventes d'art
d'entrée donc finalement dans une
dans une finale supérieure s'il si
rodgers échange les dames donc d'un
mandat le suivi de tout reprend dames le
plan de gary est très simple dans cette
position une fois que donc là le rogers
doit jouer à coup comme h3 pour éviter
le maître du couloir et la casa sports
n'a plus qu'à chasser ce fou de b3 en
jouant à 5 par exemple suivi 2 à 4 et et
où est également monté sa tour sur la
deuxième rangée et tourner deux et on
voit que dont il va raser raser les
pions voilà tout simplement et peut
probablement aussi tu acceptes donc la
seule chance de rogers dans cette
position après d'amd 4 il ne peut pas
échanger les dames sinon comme l'a dit
jean luc il ya un plan très simple pour
garry kasparov on pousse tokyo - on
déstabilise de fougue et 3e set et on
gagne donc effectivement c'est assez
problématique il faut qu'ils gardent les
dames pour continuer à avoir des chances
d'attaquer ce roi donc il joue très
logiquement dames 2 continue à défendre
le clan b2 c'est normal garry kasparov
et mc5 on sent qu'il patauge un peu le
graal kasparov a exaucé ça car c'est un
comprend même jean-luc on a beaucoup de
malades oui non de 1600 kg et un coup
intéressant que j'ai baissé ils
contrôlent toujours les cases noires
donc les quinze mois où les blancs
peuvent laisser trouver des contrôles
jeu sur le roi g7
toutes ces trois là donc ces trois là
sont contrôlés par la dame il défend son
plan b 5 et il libère la colonne des
pour sa tour des huit donc maintenant il
va peut-être essayer de doubler les
tours enfin de d'améliorer son chef pour
des histoires si c'est bon tu autour de
ses citoyens c'est sans état d'âme
protège aussi les fuites donc ce pion ne
pourra jamais certain une question donc
pas si mal passé
on appelle ça une quasi multifonctions
autre avantage on va le voir c'est dans
la partie
ian rogers shaw h3 un coup
prophylactique qui par le maître du
couloir donc on ne sait pas quoi faire
part aux maîtres du couloir à 5
le plan qu'on avait dit tout à l'heure
il veut déstabiliser on veut chasser le
fou donc la rogers de jouer à trois pour
regarder le foot seul en diagonale
pousser un pion en finale sait jamais
mauvais winch surtout face à jean-luc
c'est quand même un principe curieux
de quoi pousser un plan final s'est
jamais mauvais c'est un homme
extrêmement responsables puissent
consacrer pions ne revient pas en
arrière c'est vrai mais bon dans cette
position où ou le pion b2 est
extrêmement fragile et où les blancs
risquent de se retrouver avec peut-être
un peu moins à l'aise ll dames on peut
penser que pousser leurs pions à qui
peut s'amuser noir ou bleu noir pour les
noirs et est intéressant parce que le
pion à 5 peut s'installer en a quatre
mais attention on peut pas dire non plus
et jamais mauvais alors on va pas dire
ça mais dans cette position là c'est
vrai que c'est jamais mauvais donc le
pion va venir sur à 4 par exemple est
fixée le cube et 2 voilà on fixe les
pions sur la couleur opposée aux fous
alors attention
normalement on a enduit toujours un fou
qui est sur la même couleur exception il
est pas bon ça ça paraît logique
et quand les pions sont pas sans même
leur que fout on contrôler toutes les
cases donc et les noires et blanches
donc c'est bien mais ici c'est
complètement faux oui est ce que il faut
mettre le fou sur les couleurs les pions
pour deux raisons c'est pour que ça se
soutiennent mutuellement
exactement lorsqu en général quand on a
une qualité de moins quand on est un fou
contre une tour le fou a tout intérêt à
être sur la couleur de ses pions parce
qu'ils les défauts exactement
donc ici tout faux pour rogers sont en
tout cas tout juste pour vérifier ce
prof qui arrive à provoquer des pions
sur la couleur opposée aux fous et donc
ça c'est des affaiblissements qui
risquent de payer par la suite honneur
qu'ils vont payer tour des six de garry
kasparov tour f1 tous réussissent très
important de mettre une tour 9,6
stéphane puisque maintenant ça soulage
la dame on voit qu'il n'ya plus besoin
de contrôler toutes les cases de cette
grande diagonale d'une tournée si ça
défend tous pour point f 6-4 en échange
desquels ceux de rodgers ne peut rien
faire d'insensé l'inversé des deux qui
est fait voler des choses
3.6 donc là on se dit le roi de kasparov
un peu dans le vent mais évidemment il a
tout calculé on sait qu'à récupérer
quand même une machine à calculer
oui puis
rodgers n'a pas énormément de coups on
voyait pas beaucoup de pièces pour
attaquer le roi le roi le roi sort un
petit peu de son cocon mais pas pour
longtemps il va revenir en jeu 7
tranquillement les cases noires sont
bien contrôlées donc c'est bruno
cette manoeuvre permet d'échanger de
simplifier un peu la position et les
problèmes de rogers restent les mêmes
c'est à dire donc du matériel en moins
et un pion b2 qui risque d'être de plus
en plus faible exactement donc dam des
deux bien vu sa d'amener 2 puisque ça
attaque à cinq
et ça crée une menace même assez forte
damages six essais signés l'un qui en
achètent avec du jeu nommé gary kasparov
a tout vu il joue à quatre
intermédiaires donc des fois simple
puisqu'une n'est plus reprise des
attaques le foot est roi fou des 5 et
maintenant c'est trop tard quand g7
on ne verra plus jamais cette
possibilité d'un magistrat proche de 7 à
menacer tour des huit plutôt fort donc
dans cette position peut-on dire que les
noirs sont permis les blancs mais non
mais non les blancs ouvriers blancs sont
sont perdants mais bon on va quand même
juste regarder un petit peu la petite
astuce qui a trouvé et rogers
donc du coup intéressant quand même
qu'il lui permet de tenir un tout petit
peu un petit peu plus longtemps mais qui
joue bekkat donc d4 l'idée c'est que si
on prend le pion en b3 la rogers
pourrait faire d'un bep 2 échecs et
émettre le roi noir dans une situation
un peu périlleuse fort délicate
alors voilà regardons bien qu on prend
b3 possibilités on ne reprend pas
embêtant on peut le faire mais on n'est
pas obligé on préfère jouer dam des deux
échecs donc l'envoi le roi n'a pas de
ghazni peu les camps h6 sa part à
laquelle agissent et maintenant mais be
back to dit tout
deux chèques donc là si le roi monte il
va être ma très vive à être mat très
vite maintenant trois coups en deux
coups d'ailleurs avec vous et 3 ont
racheté 4 et d'un mètre quatre matches
voilà et si on joue g5
il y en a acheté 5 h théâtre qui a l'air
très fort sens de la smat h4 matin par
alain enfin matt probable est encore
davos est pour défendre enfin bon ici
c'est une et blanc ne sont plus en
difficulté c'est pas vraiment nécessaire
donc pour gary de ce que dans des
situations aussi acrobatique il faut
absolument pas laisser d'un bep 2 échecs
alors qu il faut il que ça l'est alors
qu'un coup de dames comme d'hab des six
locaux diaries qui est bien moins salée
mais très fort donc couvre les cases
noires comme tout à l'heure donc
finalement gary qui est fidèle
fidèle à la thématique aux échecs donc
toujours un joueur qui privilégie donc
les concepts les concepts l'aspect
esthétique un petit peu donc du jeu on
en géométrie qu'aux à géométrie qui
jouent des choses très compliquées et il
suit toujours donc cette idée de devoir
le laisser à son adversaire la
possibilité d' affaiblir les cases
blanches le plus loin possible jusqu'à
jusqu'à son droit jusqu'à 100 jusqu'à
son domicile
mais il a il a tout prévu il a prévu
donc donc dire que la gacilly et garry
kasparov il y arriver
à son maximum puisque maintenant le pion
à 3 peut plus être défendu par le foot
y'a plus qu'à jouer à 9,6 contrôlant
bien le plus bref défendant bien droit
et passer la tour pour les cherchait
depuis un an à 3 tout simplement est
donc là nathan c'est très simple vérité
soir une question techniquement gagnante
donc à celui d'amd quatre échecs dames
f6 rejet d'un même si c'est des forces
et puisque ce rouage 6 en or les dames
h4 avec panache au perpétuel
oui c'est juste dame prend dame donc là
je crois que c'est la fin des temps dams
et c'est la cagoule
il ne reprendra donc le rôtisseur à
nouveau mais qui va probablement revenir
en sommes et ce que nous devons
maintenant il va ce petit vélo à
mesquite ce qu'il faut voir c'est
pourquoi regards s'échangent les dames
c'est évidemment parce qu'il a poussé
six ans cette mission elle attaque
bessin 4 à 4
ça c'est l'idée ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que de la position où il a pris cette
option là et perdu ces trois là à des
petites chances de faire du bien que si
ça soit j'ai trois âges de sa soit nul
directement là on voit que lecture h de
g3 ce n'est pas une bonne nouvelle donc
là là on parle en théorie évidemment
puisque ça n'arrivera pas mais si vous
avez une finale tous deux pions entre
fous d'options donc placé sur l'année
mail et bien si vous avez un fou cases
blanches avec des pions et je devais
trois ans c'est nul ça c'est ya rien à
faire les noirs ne peuvent pas passer
mais encore une fois garé et tout prévu
gary a tout prévu une fois de plus
surtout ses 6 il fait tout reprend f7
élimine le pion fou prend b5 et tour à
sept îles le pion à 4 doit
impérativement à regarder et l'adoption
s'aperçoit c'est qu'une fois de plus le
roi de garry kasparov et active beaucoup
mieux placée avec -3 devient dangereux
et de monde qu'à rentrer dans le camp
des loges quand b2 pour aller manger le
pion à dreux où aller manger le pion à 3
libérés le pion à 4 surtout qu'ils
valent et qui va aller à dame donc le
reste n'est plus qu'une question de
technique après fou ces six en lice
merveilleuse plombé rouages 2 aura des
quatre espoirs offre la saignée dans ses
mathématiques b53 c'est simple on stoppe
le pjd est d'abord et qu'est ce qu'on
voit c'est que maintenant qu'il ya eu b5
et poussé 6 le fou c6 natale culture à 4
donc changement des rôles inversion des
rôles leur romance et 5 vient contrôler
plombé et maintenant c'est la tour qui
va passer pour répandre le pion à 3 ans
et 5
manger 3 laurent blanc est vraiment trop
loin de l'action tous rêvent cette geste
technique on coupe le roi blanc projet
quatre tours f2f deux rouages expérience
je vois jouer peut-être le coup b6
bessire airois processus et systèmes et
c'est ça l'idée très fan c'est que ce
roi prophéties sont je vous prends un
nul c'est dans la rue pour faire le fou
mais le problème c'est que des six est
bien mais faut en effet défendre non
plus nos proches et 5 les blancs tente
quelque chose mais gary kasparov et la
tour à deux et on voit qu'un fou a
beaucoup de mal à stopper un pion c'est
le problème
fu hobbit voilà la menace de 6 menace
des sites mais 3.30 human trop d'un
maestro ta b 6 3 points b 6 6 3 5 est la
dernière chance de rodgers était un
oubli de garry kasparov qui aurait
permis fou prend pions avec ce genre mon
aprilia 7 et g6 et on commence à pousser
ouais mais évidemment ça n'arrive pas
ici on peut envisager après avoir fait
un croix prend à ce stade par exemple
mais un simple coup comme tanger trois
touches g iii tout à fait maintenant
jusqu'à le pion à vale vale la dame vous
penchez s'ils sont faits pour alain
tourre pamfou j-6 tout à fait stéphane
et on fait d'un mais la dame permettrait
clients en arrêter les deux pions gestes
techniques
c'était en fait on ne permet pas à 3 x y
z qui pourrait permettre au foot se
sacrifier on sacrifie directement la
tour sur le fou et après on reprend et
bien ne peut sans plomb et là d'un coup
ces dames ensuite une dame contrat
d'option ça gagne de manière assez
évidente oui jean luc un petit mot pour
résumer cette page je crois que cette
partie dont il ya eu deux leçons
principales attiré donc de cette partie
c'est que donc garry kasparov a excellé
dans sa stratégie de laisser un petit
peu de laisser un petit peu à
l'adversaire assemblant d'attac
oui et pour finalement occuper le centre
et activé ses pièces et prendre
l'initiative et dans la phase technique
de la partie il a su quand il fallait
changer des pièces donc il a échangé les
tours mais il n'a pas tout échange et
condom qu'il n'a pas tout est changé on
constate quand même qu'il a c'est qu'il
a su aussi qu'il fallait garder quelques
pièces il a gardé le pion à 4 il aurait
pu décider donc d'échanger le pure at
heart et prendre tous les pions mais il
a compris donc
il a compris évidemment immédiatement
compris enfin il a tout compris voilà on
va peut-être résumer cette partie par
phases en fait l'ouverture après cet
affaiblissement de structures de fonds
des noirs contre la paire de fou ensuite
garry kasparov donc a plutôt bien joué
il a menacé d' arriver sur la case aux
cartes avec son cavalier menacé de
prendre le centre prendre le contrôle de
toutes les cases sans quoi rodgers a été
obligé lui même de contre-attaqué de
jouer car audio 5 1 et 4 une fois qu'il
a geosea garry kasparov a fait jouer ses
deux fours gens c'est ça de mes cinq est
de fous les hachoirs la table hachoir
ensuite nul 5 une physicalité de rogers
et la technique de garry kasparov la
technique qu'on lui connaît n'a permis
de remporter cette partie
retour à l'actualité stéphane avec une
très brillante victoire la victoire de
hicham hamdouchi qui est donc le
meilleur joueur africain de tous les
temps
mouallem le dire ouais c'est à dire
qu'il ya eu le plus fort jamais dans
l'histoire du monde
il ya télécharment 2595 2360 dont il est
champion du continent africain à doter
le continent africain devient de plus en
plus fort puisque maintenant il ya
pratiquement que des foires titre est
donc riche à l'indochine guaino tournoi
il ya qu baise junte qui avait joué le
champion du monde fis des ya deux ans
également à l'intérieur donc il ya des
juges ou égyptiens six motos way qui est
aussi très fort
belkhodja sur tous les tableaux mais qui
est tunisien puisque la jeune championne
de france
ouais et il joue aussi le championnat
d'afrique tissir joueurs marocains
rezzouk également joueur algérien donc
que des maîtres internationaux et hicham
hamdouchi remporté le tournoi assez
facilement donc félicitations aux
brillants seconds ans laurent frayssinet
donc ya même de shiki et qui est un
joueur très sympathique qui arrivé en
france il ya une dizaine d'années et qui
a fait donc qui a évolué au club de
montpellier et qui a fait des résultats
extraordinaires qui a une belle carrière
qui est commenté la coupe du monde
d'échecs rapide à cannes avec notre ami
d'avenir le basique alors en fait non il
a commenté de championnat de france de
marseille
si tu pouvais pas à quel coût du monde
était commentée par jean luc chatel
jean luc et laurent faut le rappeler
également vous qu'ils
le championnat d'europe des clubs qui se
déroule en crète donc tournoi où il ya
principalement dans l'équipe russe en
août une équipe française j'ai pas vu
comme ça ce n'est pas l'équipe française
et bien parce que le temps doux et l'on
demande un budget considérable comme les
clubs de dépense tout pour le
championnat de france elle ne reste plus
rien pour le champion d'europe
ah oui c'est un accident il y avait un
club qualifié il y avait trois clubs
qualifiés
je crois que les chicanes à cannes
d'ailleurs qui menaçait d'y aller
jean-luc week-end donc il y avait
envisagé d'aller jouer donc ce
championnat d'europe mais mais
apparemment c'était un championnat qui
était un peu trop coûteux donc par
rapport par rapport aux chances
d'obtenir évidemment une des médailles
donc peut-être une leçon à tirer donc
pour la fédération européenne donc
essayer de de faciliter un petit peu la
tâche les des clubs qui ont déjà des
championnats très très lourd donc leur
donner un peu la possibilité de jouer
ces compétitions internationales qui
sont très importantes pour les joueurs
toujours problème d'argent problèmes
d'argent on va peut-être en parler un
petit peu ce n'est pas avec les preuves
que canal web connaît en ce moment où on
ne peut pas taire ce problème puisque
nous savons que nous allons déposer le
bilan
voyez donc ça veut pas dire que ça
s'arrête ça ne veut pas dire que ça sert
à rien c'est que ça veut dire exactement
d'ailleurs donc ça veut dire que ça veut
dire que là
l'entreprise va mal va mal mais ça veut
dire qu'elle ne peut plus payer dépose
son bilan dont qu'elle arrête de payer
ses fournisseurs et pouvait tout ce qui
s'ensuit
les actionnaires historiques perdre ce
qu'ils ont pu mais quand donc la plus
canon elle n'appartient plus aux
actionnaires
voilà vingt ans n'ont pour l'instant
voilà c'est un attente il ya quinze
jours de latence donc que le tribunal de
commerce décide de savoir il ya deux
solutions soit la liquidation propres de
canal c'est à dire qu'on vend tout ce
qui tout ce qui peut être vendu et on
essaie de rembourser ses petits doigts
lettre est un vrai don de stéphane adam
nom renvoie le matériel en panne
matérielle et et sinon il ya un
repreneur qui qui peut qui peut faire
apparition d'ici 15 jours et reprendre
canal web un prix qui va être alors j'ai
pas partie s'est décidée ce prix je sais
pas du tout parce qu'il devait avoir un
prix minimum quand même puisque là une
valeur au moins du matériel des locaux
et c'est donc un repreneur qui pourrait
continuer l'activité qu'il est possible
de racheter le packaging
voilà
donc la marque canal web la marque
diagonale qui inclut secondes et voilà
les machines
ouais les archives les archives et ainsi
de suite
donc si jamais vous ou votre entourage
avait donc la somme qui était demandé je
crois que c'était au tour de trois
millions d'euros
ouais 3 une au dos vous pouvez vous y
mettre plusieurs d'ailleurs vous pouvez
sauver diagonale puisque pour l'instant
il n'allait pas encore sauvé 1 les gones
à l'airé risque quand même de
disparaître
ouais mais tu peux pas vous le cacher
donc si jamais vous êtes des habits
investisseurs qui aiment les échecs et
bien ils peuvent sauver des gones à
halle il ne tient qu'à eux
donc jean lucas proposait déjà de mettre
différents dans le pot oui alors non
alors oui il pour ça je vous invite
vraiment regardé l'émission de l ess
andros arnaud jacques rosselin donc qui
est donc sur le bilan du bébé eh bien
vous verrez qu'on n'accepte pas les noms
trop petit jacques rosselin est
d'ailleurs tout à fait véhément contre
les les petits les petits important à
faire voilà donc je crois qu'on va
terminer là cette édition en vous
remerciant d'avoir suivi donc stephen on
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
s'il veut il ya encore au moins deux
semaines au moins deux semaines donc au
moins deux semaines d'émission on fera
évidemment une spéciale pour la dernière
où tous les invités qui sont déjà venus
reviendrons ouais ouais
s'il ya une dernière si ça ça dépend de
vous et de nous jean-luc merci beaucoup
d'être venu de guyane directement de
l'avion jusqu'ici oui ça m'a fait
plaisir puisque j'essaie de participer
un petit peu donc l aventure qui n'est
pas encore finie laventure donc de
diagonale et de canal web également eh
bien merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
édition vous donne rendez vous mardi
pour une leçon encore peut-être sur la
défense new york est évidemment vendredi
prochain pour une émission de diagonale
actu au revoir
qui